welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host definition
aka robert fattinson and we're here at
the final final panel this is the last
one i'm going to be covering
and it's also the one that i'm probably
hyped for the most
i haven't checked out this trailer yet
but throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down everything that you
need to know about it
there may be some spoilers here as i
will be talking about some of the leaks
that i've heard
so if you want to go into this as blind
as a bat then i highly suggest that you
turn off now we don't know if they're
for definite or not
but again i don't want to ruin the movie
for anyone who wants to go in just to
just enjoy it without the way thank you
for clicking this
now let's get into the trailer
okay so that looked like it was the
riddler um
and just looking at the guy's house that
his victim there
um it's quite a nice like the decor
and the upholstery i'm sorry i'm very
posh there it looks very very nice
now there were leaks that the riddler
was basically going around
and killing high-ranking gotham
officials one of them
being the d.a gil coulson and it looks
like this is sort of the environment
that that the da would live in
it's really posh now what this also
allows is
if the da's dead that allows someone
else to step into the position of the da
it could lead to harvey dent down the
line now we will see but
that that's kind of what i'm taking from
this
okay and there is the no more lies
picture this was leaked a couple of
months ago warner brothers took it down
straight away
and as we can see it is legitimate now
we do know for definite that this was
part of the film gil coulson
is every interview that i've seen he's
been referred to as a liar
the the tapia says no more lies so
kind of joining those two things
together um but that's kind of what i'm
thinking that
chair in the background as well that's
also you might remember that matt reeves
showed the clapper board
on the first day of shooting which seems
like a lifetime ago but that was the
chair that they used and
looks very uh just the the the tone
all grounded very very menacing loving
this so far
okay and there's uh james gordon from
your secret friend
they're obviously investigating gil cole
death there if it is
coulson who you could also hear robert
pattinson's batman voice there
okay so i'm quite i'm quite digging the
the get up here he looks
you know what he looks really good
okay this sort of has a feeling of like
an old timely westin almost
the wooden floor the boots coming in and
taking focus
really really stylistic that this just
looks very very grounded you know it's
not over the top with
special effects it's just very very raw
and i'm really really enjoying it so far
lies again and don's done it again that
says so that i'm guessing that must be
the mayor there were lots of rumors as
well that the mayor was killed and this
led to a funeral scene
so this could be the mayor that was
murdered here
let's play a game okay so this is
obviously a clue from the riddler
what what does it wear when dead i don't
know having a clue let's play a game
now this kind of reminds me a lot of um
jigsaw from saw
with the clues left behind let's play a
game yeah i'm really
enjoying that and obviously you've got
the green envelope behind the card which
is
of course the riddler's uh signature
color any of this mean anything
to you to the batman wow
okay very very menacing
i love that suit i am seeing it in
motion as well
very menacing it's very sleek now this
is obviously a yeah two batman so he's
quite trim
and this looks fantastic
okay so that looks like it might be the
may um he's standing in front of a
podium
i think that's a guy trevor from
eastenders
i'll tell you they should get him back
for what he did a little mo
now he's obviously the mayor um and they
might be protecting him because it could
have been gil
coulson that was murdered at the start
holding a press conference and there
we've got robert pattinson's
black eye makeup now i mentioned this
before in
all of the the batman movie appearances
they've never had black eye makeup for
some reason
whenever he's had the cowl on he takes
it off there's
stuff underneath nothing underneath
sorry and you can clearly see when he's
wearing the mask that there is
and i've always wondered why they never
went into that here though i'm so glad
they did because it just makes it so
much more intimidating
and that's brilliant to see i'm also
guessing though that this removes the
possibility of white eyes
as why would you wear makeup underneath
if that you know had white eyes to cover
them
you're becoming quiet and that looked
like it was the motorbike scene
um so you might remember there was a
news scene though
basically what happened was robert
pattinson as bruce wayne showed up at
this scene to him
see what was going on he's sort of
acting like a sort of vampire almost now
this kind of ties into batman year one
in which
the character was sort of a vampire he
even had fake
teeth to intimidate foes and he rode
around on a motorbike as well
very sleek design so it does look like
they're kind of pulling from that a bit
you're becoming quiet and there's the
motorbike alfred we could hear there as
well
okay and there is the funeral scene so
it was leaked that during
the funeral scene for the mayor the
riddler rides in and
basically causes havoc which we've
clearly just seen there we also saw what
bruce wayne looked like
you know a bit like toby maguire in
spider-man
3 but i i think it's all right i think
by the looks of it they're doing a
completely different take to anything
that we've seen before and i'm really
really feeling it
okay so he's sent in a hostage with
another
another clue why is he writing to you
there's catwoman okay so she does sort
of
look you know they are teasing at the
costume here but it doesn't look like
the full reveal now it was said
that we would get a cat suit reveal we
might later in the trailer but
for the meantime she's just sort of a
cat burglar
if and there are there penguins
gangs um so the penguin is basically
his mob have black and white face paint
now they often get confused with the
joker gang
but this is definitely the penguins gang
okay so batman is fighting catwoman
there now
it's also said that it's gonna pull from
the long halloween in that
graphic novel catwoman breaks into
carmine falcone's house one night
to steal his ledger um full of names and
addresses batman also does it there so
they can get
basically a list of mobsters in gotham
and they do have a fight
and looks like they're kind of pulling
from that as well
very very like daredevil especially in
the combat
vengeance okay amazing
oh there's a batmobile looks incredible
kind of ape batman begins there a bit
when he was shooting up
the the staircase
again though really really love the
afterburner on the car
getting shot amazing
and that score as well that's phenomenal
and there's the logo coming together and
looks incredible
okay
okay so they're kind of teasing a
connection with batman and the riddler
um going back to the comics can't
really think of a time where they've
been pulled together but you know they
might redo something where
thomas wayne was um connected to the
riddler
and the riddler's trying to get
vengeance on batman
now in the comic books the riddler
figures out who batman is
and he uses this knowledge to sort of
basically terrorize him and this could
be why he's doing the same thing
here don't know for definite but that's
just sort of what i'm taking from this
excellent excellent trailer though very
you know that was worth
that was worth sitting and doing seven
hours of non-stop work for
really i've got goosebumps basically um
it's very very late right now so i'm not
as ecstatic
but you know what i've had a great time
um so yeah let me know your thoughts on
the trailer in the comment section below
thank you for sticking with me today
i've massively appreciated all your kind
words and if you've enjoyed the coverage
then please drop a thumbs up as it makes
a huge difference to the channel
we're going to be sort of recapping dc
fandom throughout the week and we've got
loads of dc things coming up so make
sure you subscribe if you haven't
we've also got loads of videos we've
already done today so make sure you
check them out
without the way though thank you for
clicking this i've been definition
you've been the best good night much
love
you